how does the computer science curriculum
change now you mentioned you mentioned
programming yeah like why would you be
when I was coming up programming as a
prestigious position like why would you
be dedicating crazy amounts of time to
become an excellent programmer like the
nature program is fundamentally changing
the nature of our entire education
system
is completely turned on its head has
anyone been able to like load that in
and like think about because it's really
turning I mean some English professors
some English teachers are beginning to
really freak out now yeah right like to
give an essay assignment then they get
back all this fantastic Pros like this
is the style of Hemingway and then they
realize they have to
completely rethink and even you know
just like we stopped teaching um
writing a script is that what you say in
English yeah handwritten yeah yeah when
when everybody started typing you know
like so much of what we teach our kids
today
yeah I mean that's
uh
everything is changing and it's
exchanging very it is it's changing very
quickly and so much of us understanding
how to deal with the big problems of the
world is through the education system
and if the education system is being
turned on its head then what what's next
it feels like having these kinds of
conversations is essential to try to
figure it out and everything is
happening so rapidly uh I don't think
there's even speaking of safety what
broad AI safety Define I don't think
most universities have courses on AI
safety it's like philosophy side and
like I I'm an educator myself so it
pains me to see this say this but I feel
our education right now is the
completely obsoleted
by what's happening you know you put a
kid into first grade
and then uh you're envisioning like and
then they're going to come out of high
school 12 years later
and you've already pre-planned now what
they're gonna learn when you're not even
sure if there's going to be any world
left to come out to like
clearly you need to have a much more
opportunistic education system that
keeps adapting itself very rapidly as
Society re-adapts the the skills that
were really useful when the curriculum
was written I mean how many of those
skills are going to get you a job in 12
years I mean seriously